there's things women could do how about
it's valentine's day or maybe your girl
misses you and she sends you a romantic
picture you're like whoa you're excited
maybe it's been a long day at work ooh
can't wait to get home she misses me
women can send those romantic pictures
but men if you send a picture of you
laying in the beach rolling around in
the sand
bending over in a speedo
when are you coming home babe
you're not going to get a positive
reaction
from stand-up comedy to podcast movies
hosting tv shows our guest today really
does it all originally from reno nevada
we have comedian cave on here to tell us
about his show at the la comedy club at
the strat how are you i'm doing great i
don't even know i didn't know you're
going to play that clip right there so
so you're you're bringing it back to
remembering where that was from well
yeah there are lots of differences i
know it's not cool to talk about that
now but uh yeah men cannot just be
lounging saying where you happen missing
yours like why are you not at work yeah
then you're in trouble but other way
around then it's okay part of that joke
goes on to say uh guys don't try to be
revealing in photos because those get
picked up you can get in trouble for
that instead just have a picture of you
in a suit going to work maybe your 401k
dangling out of your briefcase yeah i
really want to see you right exactly
well you're bringing all the laughs
you're from nevada originally you said
las vegas is now home for you how does
it feel to be performing at the start of
the new comedy club well i graduated
from simran memorial high school i love
it and all my friends were lds mormons
in school nicest people in the world so
my comedy i have to be ready that they
might be here in las vegas at any time
so it's pg 13 ish is that okay
yes yes that's the thing and it's still
las vegas so it's not a children's show
but uh we have a lot of fun and uh
we have the best all you can drink
special in las vegas now my lds friends
won't take advantage
but 25 bucks and you can drink as much
as you want and you know the more you
drink the funnier i get oh i love it and
you know i grew up here in vegas here i
went to palo verde high school same
thing i had a lot of lds friends so i
get it and i love that you kind of
played that into your act but you're
you're doing so much i mean you're now
dabbling into acting and podcasts and
how do you do it all well that's how it
all ties in um there was a director that
saw my clean comedy clip
and put me in a movie
after i auditioned of course and it was
with napoleon dynamite's john heater yes
that's awesome and he's lds so it just
keeps going around in circles like maybe
they're trying to recruit me the really
hard way i think that's what's happening
here
well it's working and what i think is
really fun i was watching some of your
videos earlier you really bring in your
persian family how do you feel about you
working them into your act well the hard
part is i'm a minority but i don't look
like it at all um i have these dark
persian circles under my eyes very sexy
circles but i have my mom's features so
i just look like a tired white guy
so you play off that
don't know i'm exotic they think i'm
exhausted it's crazy
but i do so i'll undo a few buttons and
i'll try to i'll try to turn up the
persian if there's women who want to
like a nice romantic you know pull up in
a carpet and kind of fly them away
you play on all of that i love it and
you wrote a book i wrote a book yeah
it's called once you go persian there's
no other version i love it but the thing
is you don't want your comedy to be so
difficult for people to understand so i
try to make it really modernized very
americanized so that you can enjoy the
journey and i've had people that are
latino and indian and asian saying i
laughed at all these stories myself yeah
everyone can kind of find something to
relate to there i gotta ask you okay so
maybe if there's one thing that people
don't know about being persian or
growing up in a persian family what is
it well persians really are known for
cats persian cats are beautiful yes and
we love watermelon a lot and i went and
got an allergy test recently and it
turns out i'm not kidding i'm allergic
to cats and watermelons
you're the worst version i know that's
like being californian and allergic to
botox and electric vehicles like i don't
know
it just doesn't go hand in hand it
doesn't work so i'm in trouble well this
is probably just a taste of what we can
expect at your show but how does it feel
to be performing at the strat in your
hometown it's gonna be great what i say
about the strat is it's a great spot and
you go up to the top and look at all the
other casinos too so but you gotta check
it out i want everyone to come and i
don't normally do this but anyone
watching if they find me on instagram or
on facebook i'm gonna give them a free
ticket first 20 people only she can't be
giving away the whole shut it off at
some point just say channel 8 and
mention her lovely name and boom that's
all that'll be the secret code oh well
we're so excited to have you out here in
vegas can't wait to see your show
everything else you're doing like we
said hosting shows podcast i don't know
how you have time to sleep well i'm on
tour right now but the stride will
always be here and they do a comedy show
at six i'm the eight o'clock and then 10
p.m so whatever time you get off work i
know we have people working the
graveyard shift come check us out you'll
have a great time well kayvon thank you
so much for being here we're so excited
for you and we'll have all the
information on your screen shows through
sunday june 12th kvon along with
augustine ozolda guests must be 18 years
or older to attend ticket prices start
at just 40 and also nevada locals with a
valid id you can receive 50 off just go
to
lacomedyclub.com thank you so much yes
you get the discounts because you know
the persian
you heard it here mercedes i'll send it
over to you